let's talk about the problems when you romanticize a 1950s homemaker aesthetic
coming from someone who's a full time
stay at home mom homemaker who loves a vintage moment
the reason videos like this can be met with negative response
is because it's erasing the entire domestic labor force that was depended upon
by these upper middle class white stay at home moms
the traditional housewife of the 1950s
1960s was never meant to do everything by themselves
they always had domestic labor
and honestly
since the Industrial Revolution
these ideas of ornamental upper class white housewives
were an offshoot and a demonstration of their husband's wealth
so these were not women who were expected to lift a finger
and yes we can idealize the fashions and the styles of the 1950s
and still enjoy being stay home wives and homemakers and mothers
while acknowledging the labor that made that possible